mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
tiens
il y en a
[Musique]
ce soit en programme de double jeu
retrouvé le goal de la semaine durant
duranne bons réflexes à israël
rock'n'roll garland jeffries très faible
mais on aime le document de la semaine
cliff richard la vo2 vous verrez manu
katché le batteur des rockstars se met à
chanter trench plus les infos intox de
philippe guérin les sales blagues de
laurent baffie philippe corti l'omoplate
indoor et en invité vedette darricau
[Musique]
souvenez d'un film
et blanc bonsoir aux légionnaires soir
c'est en quoi mon fils où je me détends
j'en avais besoin
vite et j'ai un truc tu fais pas de la
télé toi fais
ta bouche nana ton émission à non je
prends des comics - kaki la reine
d'angleterre à paris à paris elle est
tellement mal habillée que l'élu à paris
se faire tailler un costard et puis et
puis j'ai celle qui astique et d'autres
bijoux de la couronne et maintenant même
la reine reconnaît plus personne en sera
ferguson sarah ferguson taki d'autres un
un mec génial
un comédien qu'on voit jamais la télé
problème c'est que l'émission radio a
duré plus longtemps que d'habitude
pourquoi dégâts si francis perrin a non
j'ai dit un comédien c'est darry cowl
wall darry cowl mais dis moi ton
émission c'est pas celle où il ya de la
forêt de la taxe absolument
et toi et d'infos grimpette tac à venir
voir
[Musique]
et
oh
dix ans marie te souviens-tu d'une
chanson qui s'appelait je crois comme
les stars que tu avais écrites pour
oublier de monter l'équipe qui pensaient
qu'ils étaient bonnes odeurs vue aux
folies bergères et avec garantie qu est
ce que tu t'en souviens je crois qu'il
avait fait un tableau d'ailleurs de
tache en son nom mais je vais la jouer
ce que je suis mal maintenant c'était à
eau puis testé vieux ça
[Musique]
c'était chez toi tu écoutes
quoi qu'est le quel genre de musique
j'improvise sais pas quoi ça dépend si
je suis de mauvaise humeur
je suis de bonne humeur c'est
[Musique]
oui
raconte moi ton meilleur souvenir
souvenirs souvenirs c'est quand j'ai
rencontré ma petite femme et
nous étions à table
et enfin si avec l'ancien que je
quittais
e
épilez les pieds sous frôlait les jeunes
aux problèmes dans son lait
c'était chaud et c'est chouette gars m'a
donné mon pied a frôlé le genou de cette
couche quitter sa secte et plus tôt
et c'était tout
et l'amour dans tout ça l'amour c'est
[Musique]
et
nous
doux
l'amour c'est sans faire c'est comme ça
sont des vapeurs plus tôt et dieu dans
tout ça
dieu est
[Musique]
et
wagner et quel est l'état présent de ton
esprit avec les tirades que j'ai au
théâtre c'est beaucoup plus
mais dans quelques jours ce sera
[Musique]
alors
on s'est dit ça va c'est vrai voilà
c'est la vraie reine d'angleterre bien
sûr on rigole pas ici est élevé darry
cowl toi tu connais sarah ferguson et
les problèmes ces derniers temps c'est
vous
ouais mais c'est fait chanter mais bien
merci elle parle bien français en plus
c'est impressionnant l'impressionnant
dix mois c'est en plus très courageux
d'être venu ce soir parce que c'était la
première de ta pièce oui ça c'est là
donc je suis je tremble encore du gratin
montra clavel traque lettres sur scène
mais ça s'est passé merveilleusement
bien
déjà on en a parlé mais mais d'abord je
voulais te dire quelque chose que tu ne
s'est peut-être pas on arge non tu est
le troisième acteur de théâtre préféré
des français
d'après une étude réalisée par le
ministère de la culture
tu le savais ça est bon la police
oui
on va parler de nina d'andré roussin mis
en scène par bernard murat que tu joues
au théâtre gaîté montparnasse
si tu avais une minute pour tous nous y
envoyer voir cette pièce qu'est ce que
tu veux bien bas d'abord d'emporter un
mouchoir parce que vous risquez d'être
d'abord de rire beaucoup d'encre essuie
les larmes de riz et puis enfin il ya
quelques coins très sensible où la
comédienne merveilleuse italienne émeut
beaucoup public donc les larmes bien des
fois des larmes mais c'est surtout drôle
c'est rousset roussin ya le drame est
très vite au bout du rire enfin ce sont
des situations
la plupart du temps pas tragique mais
traumatique
alors voilà donc les gens sont ravis
parce que il y a pour tous les goûts
alors à prendre les choses dans l'ordre
d'arrivée si tu veux bien j'ai de faire
une interview première fois et tu vas un
petit peu nous raconter tes premières
impressions dans la vie tu es premières
émotions
à commencer par ton premier nom qui bien
entendu n'est pas darry cowl non on
m'appelle darricau andry alors ton
arrière grand père était le médecin de
napoléon est ce que c'est mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais quand tu sais tout
ça c'est frais c'est lui qui t'a donné
le secret de l'éternelle jeunesse parce
qu'on peut dire tournage quand même dans
66 ans soit en disant tu te rends compte
et toute ma dent et tout comme tu es
bien à 66 ans je suis pas du tout je
suis bien là dedans je suis bien là d'un
le reste j'ai un moral d'acier
ouais y'a pas que ça non plus enfin
pendant que l'on se crée alors comment
mon secret rière je bois beaucoup d'eau
je vois obligée de la vie
j'aimais chaque seconde de la vie je la
savoure du pic chaumont d'ailleurs un
non dit que les signes de la vieillesse
ne marque pas sur les gens un peu
névrosé c'est peut-être parce que tu as
un peu fou alors tu dis pas non c'est
possible non je ne sais pas les choses
les choses n'ont pas beaucoup d'impact
sur moi les bonnes d'ailleurs comme les
mauvaises ainsi vaincre a glissé je
crois que quand ça glisse fait remarquer
quand on envoie des cahiers de rouleaux
qui fait des ricochets ça des scans pas
la mer c'est joli ce que je dis c'est
pas mal
alors voilà donc je suis une mère et les
ricochets ne m'attaque pas ton premier
souvenir tu t'en souviens quand on va
pendu par les pieds comme ce court j'ai
pas un souvenir charmant puis après ça a
été ça a été tout c'était la femme la
rencontre de d'un corps de femme parce
que finalement tu as eu quand même eu un
début de vie s'est agité dans la mesure
où tu entends ton père était un grand
chirurgien du pays basque ma vraie mère
j'ai jamais connu m'avait à ma mère ma
vraie mais ma réelle jamais connu étant
l'issue de bourgeois basse que mon père
avait fauté un petit peu quelque part et
de ce fait
l'accouchement s'est produit loin loin
les basques donc ma famille on a
toujours cachée mais ces voix là on s'y
fait à mon âge si je pars j'ai arrêté
les recherches c'est quand tu as appris
ça le premier choc de ta vie non c'est
une arme vers l'âge de 10 ans ça je la
pris un peu plus tard mais le premier
choc c'est que cette dame je lâche la
comprends très bien ne m'a jamais aimé
bastien l'accepter de m'éduquer mais ne
m'a jamais aimé et là c'en est un peu
souffert les sources d'eau souffert de
la disparition de mon père qui était un
être extraordinaire
donc il ya un vide quelque part c'est
certain mais après ça a expliqué que à
17 ans je me suis est temps de mettre en
fait et vend 6 p j'ai épousé une femme
de 36 ans à 17 ans donc cg j'ai fait
l'amour avec une femme qui était ma mère
pratiquement mais tu as ta vraie merde a
tout fait pour la retrouver tu as dit
une fois devait déclarer une fois
j'aurais acheté tout le pays bas s'il
fallait c'est fabuleux tu sais tout
enfin j'ai pas les moyens d'acheter
soultzbach mais j'ai tout fait pour
essayer j'ai proposé des sommes assez
importantes même pour le retrouver mais
après j'ai renoncé parce que c'était du
jour secrète et d'issia ce qu'on a
envoyé à melbourne il ya peut-être pas
loin
qu'est-ce qui est fixée comme ça et qui
fixe la bahassa portrait et une photo
phil messelet son premier flirt tu t'en
souviens c'était ma nourrice 1
mais je m'en suis là c'est quand j'ai
plus aimés l'est ouais
et puis c'est toujours été amoureuse et
je vais de fleur en fleur
en fait j'ai une petite fille petite à
une petite cambodgienne de qui j'étais
très très amoureux nous allons tous les
deux dans les toilettes
enfin je vous dirai pas toujours sa
première cuite
la première donc c'est avant les 4000
autres à temps la première s'est évadé
du plâne j'étais en voiture et j'ai vu
dix mille voitures qui venaient
vers moi et moi je vais 46 vols en
réunion
c'est ta première expérience sexuelle ça
s'est passé avec une [ __ ] air charmante
bien belle gueule ça c'est pas ça
pigalle à l'époque y avait pas de
problème il n'y a pas de craintes à
avoir tellement et puis alors ça a duré
exactement 14 4 secondes tout compris
tout compris tout compris et cette femme
est tombée amoureuse de moi elle avait
dans le fond macro laver sans gigolo et
j'étais agréés par les deux et j'ai vu
ne peut pas vécu elle m'a éduqué s'était
montré les inverse traîner ça parle
d'amour mais j'ai fait mes armes j'ai
fait mon service militaire avec les
pendant deux ans et quand j'ai le
conservatoire dans le belleville
j'allais donc gare saint lazare et le 26
passait dans le banat midi pyrénées où
elle habitait et je partais une heure et
demie avant pour bonjour madame
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
alors elle me disait tu vas toi pour le
calme on n'apprend pas en amour mais
elle m'a elle m'a en tout cas aider à
pouvoir tenir
enfin on sait très bien aussi dit à tony
de pouvoir entre valides pendant
longtemps son premier succès en premier
vrai succès ben ça a été
je crois que c'était le film à guitry
assassins voleurs donc dans lesquels
j'étais je me trompais de deux salles
d'audience
le triporteur c'est venu après très vite
après c'est quand même énorme succès ça
a été un gros truc oui mais après j'ai
dû m'arrêter en fait j'aurais dû
m'arrêter comme ça serait resté sur un
gros succès après j'ai fait 120 corps
par l'esprit d'un premier procès or
c'est délicat remettez pas un procès non
c'était au divorce avec ma femme qui
était puisque je me suis marié tu dis
avait 17 ans elle avait 36 ans et deux
mois après la pause à tromper comme pas
possible ce qui était normal en fait
normal vu la différence d'argile
il a fallu divorce est ton premier
mariage c'était celui-là c'était
celui-là est le deuxième mariage acs
avait 36 ans qu'ils aient eu lieu
c'était maintenant quatre ans je demande
deux fois oui maintenant si celle ci est
dérangé feuillade et maintenance de
d'accord
sa dernière volonté ce serait quoi de
n'en avoir jamais est ce que tu crois
que le paradis ressemble à eurodisney je
crois que c'est mieux parce que c'est
moins cher
ouais et puis je vois qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de ya beaucoup de jeu il ya eu non
plus de grande joie alors est ce que tu
crois que l'on faire ressemble à
mirapolis l'ont fait faut-il croire
d'abord pour s'imaginer or j'y crois pas
tellement mais la police n'y est pas
allé non mais j'y crois mais je te
montrer un truc tu regardes tu prends
ton petit et les regarde le colosse
avait les pieds d'argile et une peur
panique des souris avant même l'arrivée
d'euro disney il tire sa révérence le
parc mirapolis ne réouvrira jamais ses
portes la note est salée
les propriétaires perdent leur mise
initiale soit 115 millions de francs
pour eux il y a urgence à récupérer une
partie de cet argent nous sommes des
investisseurs des banquiers pas des
exploitants on se retrouve pour pouvoir
couvrir notre créance propriétaire de 82
ha bien évidemment il faut que nous en
séparer
donc ils sont en vente situés sur la
ville nouvelle de cergy-pontoise siège
de nombreuses multinationales les
terrains sont idéalement placés cela n'a
pas échappé aux gestionnaires du
patrimoine de la reine d'angleterre la
femme la plus riche du monde
je pense que la reine isabelle possède
des collections d'art et sava importante
des résidences notamment à l'île
moustique des terrains aux états unis de
nombreux terrains l'angleterre de
nombreux immeubles et pourquoi pas bien
sur ces terrains police qui pourrait
représenter un intérêt pour un
investissement ces tractations sont bien
évidemment menée dans le plus grand
secret ces lagunes et les méthodes d'une
société immobilière dont la couronne
britannique détient la majorité qui
réalisera la transaction cet
investissement a été révélé pour qui
sait lire entre les lignes dans le livre
elisabeth et philippe plusieurs passages
compte allusion un projet d'acquisition
de terrains en normandie
dépité par les chefs de mirapolis les
riverains n'apprécie guère l'initiative
royale
j'ai rien contre elle personnellement
enfin sache est déjà toute nouvelle
maison en normandie
mikari
deux mondes et pourtant il va falloir se
faire à l'idée de vivre une anglaise
les manèges devrait céder leur place à
un parc résidentiel regroupant autour
d'un golf et d'un centre équestre des
cottage un hôtel et un pub
[Musique]
rachète les terrains de mirapolis la
reine d'angleterre les terrains de
mirapolis s de l'info s de l'intox
d'harry à l'oreille que je dis si c'est
vrai voilà un bon il faut le dire
vraiment ah non tu me l'a dit maintenant
avoir d'accord pose jamais tu veux pas
être un peu plus pressé si audi ouais s
de l'info est de l'intox majesté à vous
de jouer
je n'étais pas c'était prévenu je ne me
suis pas déplacé donc je pense que c'est
de l'intox l'intox ça oui je crois que
l'ex headline dox de la coque ceci oui
vous êtes sur toutes les deux qu'est-ce
que tu m'a dit toi tu irais vrai toi tu
commence très fort on écoute l'expert
philippe gas
hérita cherchait à implanter là bas
mènent tous les genres de la famille et
après tu veux qu'ils s'étaient bien bien
sûr c'était de l'intox c'est de l'intox
alors un commentaire c'est de l'intox
mais je voudrais profiter de ce sujet
pour frais haché un peu de trac pour
vous offrir madame huguette funfrock un
petit poème que j'ai écris moi même au
toit huguette la rambarde les sosies
face à ceux qui te guette aux toiles
gate qui sait ne pas crier quand on te
fouette j'aimerais te faire un baiser
merci
est ce que tu peux le faire en verre non
je vais te donner le score envers et
contre tout ça fait un partout pour la
vieille peau et la [ __ ] a alors garé
il ya deux clichés quitte en quittant
rendu célèbre et oui c'est d'abord tombé
gaiement en fait on ex-belle gaiement
parce que tu es gay plus du tout et puis
c'est ouhlala petit canaillou oui tu
peux nous enfermant un des halls à la
psychanalyse pour mémoire quoi
et vous voudriez vous prodiguer des gg
je n'ai plus pu faire terry leon d'avoir
fait ça j'étais le bois ta rondes c'est
un grand club ça pas pourquoi je les dis
ça j'ai pas dans un film dans le
triporteur je crois avec les motards qui
marc était petit zoom optique et ou
petit monde médical que je vous ai mis
deux bières et d'ayew alors c'est vrai
que le bégaiement départ a commencé un
jour où une vieille tante pour punir ta
pendu par les pieds du troisième étage
au dessus du vide 2e 2e
qu'est ce que ça aurait été sa vettel 3e
dans le quatrième mais le oui j'ai fait
j'ai fait une blague idiote et gagnent
plus depuis je fais que plus jamais je
fais la moindre blagué entre horreur de
ça je m'étais caché dans les colonnes de
l'église de menton et
dégagez j'avais un revolver j'ai tenue
de cow-boy et comment elle passait
derrière le pilon jeu surgi au les
maires vraiment et la pauvre chez elle à
la féclaz qui tombe à l'époque tout ça
est donc qu elle m'a raccompagné à la
maison pour me punir la bonne graine au
courant m'a pris par la peau des fesses
elle aurait pu vérifier si mes boutons
de culotte tenait toujours eue elle m'a
suspendu par lors de trois minutes un
deuxième étage qui est très méchant et
ce qui m'a fait bégayer de bégayer
mais ceci dit j'ai un bégaiement
beaucoup plus mental que bucarest où se
bousculent dans ma tête c'est pour le
port pendant je te parle là je pense à
ce que j'ai fait ce soir au terrain
je pense à demain les toutefois amélioré
je pense à je pense à charge pour ça et
là au début de ta carrière donc tu tu
t'es le bec de service et on te disait
dire les gens te disent écoutez ce le
texte est pas grave vous mettez dans un
coin vous bégayer ça ira très bien que
c'était peut-être aux trois baudets
djoudi piano ayant tous les numéros je
devais forcément raconter des histoires
et pas drôle du tout mais les gens
riaient uniquement sur le bégaiement
alors je raconte une histoire je sais
pas monsieur fait de la pêche sous
marine
et là je disais que ça pendant deux
minutes et arqués formidable c'est quand
je rencontre un vrai avec un vrai bug
pour se dire bonjour à tous les deux en
revanche il nous faut environ un quart
de sa dure un quart d'heure parce que le
bec mois un bec face à un bug il se dit
berges médias aussi et ça crée des
problèmes et là on se alors depuis quand
on voit un bec et conseiller des bugs on
s'est vite s colitti bégaye pour une
femme savait très bien que ça doit
augmenter le plaisir de la tente
si c'était là devant elle comme ça on va
lui parler vite je met à bégayer salut
je crois que je suis trop occupé à autre
le plaisir de la tente qu'il n'est pas
avec une femme elle a quand même un
volant non je crois je suis occupé à
trop de choses pour bégayer à ce moment
là et on a bourg en fait on ne parle pas
donc je suis sauvé tu as essayé les
orthophonistes noms dont la psychanalyse
non non et c'est à passer comment dont
j'ai essayé le tir à la carabine mais
c'est toutefois le rapport mais tu l'as
vécu comme un un avantage ou un handicap
dans la handicape honorant handicapés
est évidemment que déjà la gueule n'est
pas fameuse mais si en plus ce qu'il en
sort s'ajuste pas d'une manière normale
c'est ce que laurent baffie et elle est
demandé aux gens dans la rue justement
si kouassi si c'est un an diction peut y
arriver quand on paye comme ça
vous connaissez le cinéma monsieur n'ont
pas beaucoup à votre avis est ce qu'il
est possible avait coûté moi de réaliser
une carrière pendant plus de trente ans
de très très bien gagner sa vie au
théâtre au cinéma en étant feignant en
buvant des coûts en jouant au piano en
jouant biya et en plus en bégayant est
possible s'il a beaucoup de chance le
cinéma sim est une bonne petite pipe un
bon grand film et au dépourvu vous
connaissez darry cowl débat faut il que
de dire qui bégaye que laisser un de ses
films oui manoeuvre pour vous donner les
titres de mémoire si vous le prenez
comme ça cette fois là qui est souvent
dépourvus lions face de vous il est sur
le plateau vous avez une question à lui
poser
je prend peut-être des pauvres il
vous m'avez empêcher de le répéter
qu'ils jouaient dans le tripoteur h ai
dit que je jouais d'un trip auteurs j'ai
bien ri dans la
david depardieu j'ai bien aimé ses films
c'est un grand acteur et un grand acteur
qui t'a ricol a trouvé sa voie et vous
me de voir des joueurs répondent grands
acteurs oui oui de turcs on parle du
même avait coûté c'est le grand comédien
qui fait beaucoup de choses en chansons
et au cinéma
eh bien il fait des navets des mauvais
films alors excusez moi je ne connais
pas leur mari cole we darry cowl moi je
n'en connais que je vous dis aux
lunettes qui bégayait c'est lui c'est 50
acteurs c'est pas un gros tracteur moi
je le trouve à 800 il est comique non
sur rien ce rien d'agricole qu'est ce
que c'est un groupe rasta un groove
rasta daddy cool
oddateee your daddy cool darry cowl moi
je connais pas vraiment pour tardez pas
je suis dans le métier je connais pas
très très grands groupes
rasta des jamaïque ou de france avec le
crimson jeu mais que je connais pas ils
font du rock de reggae recall moi je
connais pas ça ça rigole à l'école non
je ne connais pas une fille médecin orl
vous avez vous renoncé manque ici si je
donne tout le lancer mais je connais pas
la ricoh les choses allaient que je
connais pas ce que je mange mais le
centre de paris ça rigole non je connais
pas il est signé tran url mais par
nicole je connais pas qui est ce que ce
sera darry cowl comme on peut darry cowl
je connais pas le monde agricole
est ce que ça t'a arraché le coeur et
dans les durs parce que il est il est
aimé il est populaire
c'était très très dur de faire un
costard de stars ouais une fois parce
que les gens l'aiment beaucoup
ouais il souhaiterait bizarrement les
gens vous aiment beaucoup d alors et
continuer ton histoire en arrivant à
paris tu t'es inscrit au conservatoire
mais parce que d'abord il y avait mon
frère tu as un peu pistonné non en faire
et à dire qu'elle avait il est passé par
le conservatoire demi frère mon double
oui mon petit frère pierre et donc du
tout pas pistonné du tout je suis rentré
dans vos boîtes noires parce qu'il y
avait des ennemis qui avait voilà
c'était me qu'il y avait des trois fois
par semaine oui c'était fabuleux ça
sympa j allais m'intéressait c'était la
fête
mais peu importe ça c'était l'important
c'est que les gt il y avait des cours
qu'il est le matin et que j
j'avais le droit d'arriver en retard de
trois heures parce que je travaillais
bien donc le cours était de 9 heures à
12h30 j'arrivais vers 11h30 site est
parfait et ça permettait d'aller faire
mes classes chez ma petite peter
ravissante espagnol alors tel tellement
le trac que ta lutte résoudre à faire du
cabaret était devenu musicien
accompagnateur et cabaret quoi alors oui
donc là haut j'ai fait rien d'autre à
baudet j'ai fait rire là bas et puis
après deux légendes et chanteurs et
chanteuses car je veux pas mal du
panneau jamais été un bon pianiste mais
c'était pas mal c'était pas mal je vous
défendez bien et donc ils m'ont pris
avec eux et j'étais donc voulu
accompagner toutes les peuples un
lamoureux jacqueline françois et puis
après tu as fait du cinéma il n'y a pas
on dit toujours que tu as fait que des
navets m'enfin on a quand même certains
qui vous a été tourné avec alegre et a
tourné avec avec audiard j'ai failli
reykjanes mais c'était région paddy riz
soit content d'ailleurs qui content de
ce qu'il a fait ouais j'accuse personnes
âgées même intervention ni les auteurs
ni dis moi d'ailleurs
moi si je prenais ce métier à la légère
maintenant je fais le contraire mais
j'ai tellement de besoins d'argent comme
tous mais moi c'est un besoin impérieux
devoir parler
et toi qui te fait rire les marx
brothers te font rien par exemple n'ont
pas beaucoup bougé gîte richard lowe
sait rien non pas du tout du tout danic
et de fait rien oui mais dont ville te
fais réincarner bourvil il faut redonner
ferland des ltte faisait rire il dit
quoi il a eu des coins très
extraordinaire mais c'est à comédiens
sont des grands comédiens cette chose et
coluche est ce que coluche te faisais
rire très fort très fort c'était un gars
très sensible très délicat et il avait
c'était un il s'était pas eu un comique
en tant que pape roxy bruce willis a été
les muscles et très grand talent les
nuls devant rien il ya des choses oui
oui il ya des choses oui moi je vais pas
dire dans toute manière mais c'est pas
des mecs des mecs comme bigard comme
timsit est ce que le client ne connaît
pas le commis de violentes qu'ils ont
pratiqué aujourd'hui c'est ce que ça te
fait rien non non il est né c'était une
mode squad opté dans le monde entier
d'ailleurs y a pas qu'en france mais le
comique je dis pas non confirmées le
comique qui à base de deux shows
d'humour noir d'humour dur je n'aime pas
beaucoup
conscient que c'était plus facile de
deux ferries rang des bilans sains tels
méchamment que de fait rire avec moins
d'alliés forts exemple ou un foulard
oui un peu comique n'insulte plaît pas
non je vais te montrer un truc sur les
insultes mais c'est un enchaînement toi
oui tu regardes tu accordes avec la
sibylle les automobilistes pouvaient
communiquer entre eux avec le scanner
ils pouvaient écouter toutes les
fréquences radios y compris celle de la
police avec le cipi scanner qu'ils
peuvent maintenant émettre sur la bande
fm et interrompre pendant quelques
secondes les coudes de n'importe quelle
station de radio
certains automobilistes ont profité de
l'appareil pour injurier par le biais
des autres radios d'autres conducteurs
ils lui ont même trouvé un nom le
scanner à un juan mais moi je vais droit
mais sur suis pas le seul je rentrais
chez moi un soir peinard par le pont de
suresnes dans une voiture un peu voyante
en écoutant la radio
il ya un gars qui me collait qu'il
voulait me passer comme il insistait moi
je voulais pas d'un seul coup dans les
haut-parleurs et entendu est plus valin
vire est à quai ce soir cru je n'ai pas
compris si le scanner à injures est
interdite en france
il est en vente libre aux états unis il
n'en fallait pas plus pour que
l'appareil se vendent sous le manteau à
paris c'est tout simplement un scanner
émetteurs c'est à dire que ça vous
envoie un message sur la bande 88 108 fm
sur un autoradio d'un automobiliste et
reçoit le message en simultanément pour
ainsi dire à condition que le poste soit
y allumer ça coûte entre 4 et 5 8 francs
suivant les modèles voilà comment ça
marche
puisque l'on parle en 1 2 3 discret et
efficace l'appareil est aussi difficile
à détecter car il a un rayon d'action de
50 mètres seulement voilà qui risque de
tendre un peu plus les rapports entre
automobilistes au risque gros si on est
pris mais comme le général des agents
savent pas trop d'où ça vient on essaie
de camoufler après la pareille en fait
une cible les cibistes souviennent
qu'ils étaient dans l'illégalité il ya
dix ans environ
aujourd'hui ils essayent de respecter
normes contraignantes donc ses
utilisateurs de scanner qu'on appelle
les femmes intruders médecine sont
minoritaires ne peuvent que relancer une
guerre des ondes et amener une polémique
tout à fait stérile bon mamie nova t
pousse-t-on podium
insulter les autres automobilistes par
radio s de l'info est de l'intox d'harry
à l'oreille j'ai pas attendu presque est
rude
quoi quoi on appareils oui pour insulter
les autres automobilistes par radio s de
l'info s de l'intox c'est à vous de
jouer sarah talent tox de l'intox
ouais mais bon voilà c'est trop facile
ah bon tu crois pas et vous majesté je
pense que ça vient en tête puisque un
appareil pour 50 mètres de distance ce
sont 1
soit tu m'as dit quoi ouais ouais tu
m'aimes toujours autant je comprends je
crois moi mais c'est très bien alors on
égoutte experts
schilliger il faut être là vraiment vous
n'êtes pas gentille avec moi c'était de
l'intox à
tu as un commentaire en filou oui mon
petit thierry nous c'était de l'intox et
c'est tant mieux parce que ce après pas
mal de morts en plus sur les routes avec
un tel système on a imaginé le scanner à
injure pour autoradio on aurait pu aussi
envisager le scanner injure pour poste
de télé histoire de créer des liens
encore plus fraternelle dans certains
grands ensembles merci les deux rugbys
se tirent une bourre d'enfer de partout
hordain et dis moi oui jamais vraiment
exprimé de tes opinions politiques s'est
jamais entendu prendre parti je suis
apolitique mais je vote
ouais je suis apolitique à voter pour
qui les régionales il ya quinze jours
faut le dire mais je sais pas oui bah
c'est toi plutôt un peu au coude et
droite avant d'accord tu regrettes pas
le mitterrand un peu d'après la
cohabitation 88 un peu père de la nation
comme ça au dessus de la mêlée je ne
regrette pas j'ai jamais regretter j'ai
jamais souhaité juin fous complètement
bach histoire bonne santé ces voix là
mais peut-être chez lui plus qu'ailleurs
voilà n'a jamais été tenté par l'idée
monarchique toi non je n'ai jamais tu es
tu crois pas que c'est comme sur un
terrain de foot c'est à dire qu'il ya
deux équipes une équipe conservatrice
une équipe progressiste et puis qu'il ya
un arbitre non non moi je préfère tarte
aux fraises
ouais le trail ouais bon on n'élit pas
arbitres le capitaine d'une des deux
équipes s'étaient jamais tenté cette
idée jamais mais je n'ai pas regardé en
europe par exemple je sais que dans
l'europe de 93 sur 12 pays aura six six
monarchies quand même s'attendre pas ce
dont je suis belge attend de voir ça
cette demande pas non ça fait beaucoup
rire mais ça me tente pas du tout
regardez l'espagne se passe bien par
exemple
oui je te remercie légiste à vendre vos
petits médicaments mais quoi je lui
parle de la monarchie mais calmez vous
justement j'aimerais multimédi que ce
programme lui parler de la monarchie non
j'ai quand même le droit de lui parler
de la monarchie médicaments
oui je parle de la monarchie mais enfin
si j'ai quand même le droit de dire ce
que je veux la télécommande la magie si
t as il est temps de prendre vos petits
cachets goudou à ce point là hulu est en
grève
on dirait que ça vous dérange pas ça ça
va oui je me suis un peu calmé un ça va
mieux là je vois oui
ça va passer ça va mieux ça y est on
peut continuer excuse moi oui c'est
regrettable mais c'est pas grave
avant si c'était un gros joueur
oui oui à propos de cacher que tu as
pris ton trou de cacher tous mes cachets
ils sont passées pratiquement tu qu'on
parle j'ai une drogue dure
oui sans roulettes était en manque il
fallait que tous les jours tu te
retrouves devant le silence est une
drogue
c'est exactement à autre chose c'est que
pour les drogués et des maisons qu'ils
soignent les drogués qui sont des
alcooliques il ya plus de maisons quasi
look un hôpital qui soigne ceux qui
jouent un jeu de hasard et a pas de cure
de désintoxication pour les possibles
mais tu veux quand tu parles du jetons
on dirait un drogué qui parle de sa
seringue
tu regardes tu le touches tullet parce
que le jeton quelque chose de miraculeux
temps c'est inhumain de jetons c'est pas
un billet de banque je suis sûr que les
joueurs joueraient avec des billets de
banques y aurait beaucoup moins de un
vrai joueur c'est le côté magique
le jeton et magique le jetons on a un
jeton et suite on l'a 30 jetons un jeton
mettons qui vaille un million de
centimes
sur 30 millions mais 30 millions n'a pas
le réveillon de d'argent euro millions
du lotto 8 à 10 gt1 guignard totale
parce que je gagnais par exemple en 10
minutes et après je perdais pendant 30
jours
mais ça a des milliers en france a donc
médias fait parce que ce jeu j'ai gagné
dans toute ma vie de joueur donc s'en
fait des années j'ai dû gagner dix fois
alors ça en fait des moments où j'ai
perdu quand tu t'es fait interdire dans
les casinos à un moment oui il vient
après qu'ils aient fait d interdire pour
être sûr que tu peux plus vivre sans
être interdite non je me suis je me suis
interdit quand on se fait interdire on
se met soudain productive la protection
de la police des moeurs est d'accord la
police des moeurs donc vous empêche de
rentrer dedans tout casino et tout sac
de jeux en france à part monter car bien
sûr et mais c'est pas se mettre sous la
protection de la police qui va guérir un
joueur c'est ne plus jouer du tout avis
être sûrs et trois ans presse déjà j'ai
demandé que dans deux ans à parce que
c'est tous les cinq ans cinq ans cinq
ans après dix ans et après avis je me
suis fait d interdire car j'étais
certain
mais depuis juillet sur des plaines fois
dans les casinos mais quand je suis
passé pour voir la gueule des pauvres
joueurs je le reconnais quelque part et
je vois toutes ces gueules qui sont les
mêmes d'ailleurs il ya toujours les îles
marquises il ya l'homme d'affaires le
pdg qui va perdre ses a fait avec le jeu
mais tu as perdu beaucoup à part de la
première femme au jeu lui compenser
moins grande croix voilà la réponse
précise mais tu joues plus du tout à
rien à la zone ont même dû à la pétanque
tu joues paolo cito entends tu vois ta
pensée de [ __ ] en l'air dans ces
moments là et non j'aime trop la vie oh
non non non mais si j'avais dû entre
autres c'est parce que la vie est trop
belle le seul regret que j'ai c'est
toutes ces heures toutes ces heures de
l'est de midi à minuit dedans du matin
devant le regard fixé sur un tapis vert
et déjà car ça c'est pas récupérable ont
pu récupérer des jetons de 40 oeuvres on
peut tous ont fait le casse d'une banque
on peut on peut se retrouver mais le
tapis vert les hold up à petit vers le
temps perdu sa 7e moche moche mais c'est
vrai que tu pouvais perdre en une nuit
le cachet d'un film comme on en une lipo
qu une nuit ça paraît énorme une vie en
ont deux en or deux suffit de distribuer
puis sympas ils ramassent est alors
appelée petit râteau et leur après tu as
fait ton agent et tu lui demandes et
rouge il n'importe lequel
- exactement la nuit quand j' ai plus
rien au casino prêté parce que c'est
leur intérêt de prêter ouais bien sûr
mais quand y avait plus rien
et qui prêtaient plus il fallait que le
lendemain ou le surlendemain j'ai signé
n'importe quoi et je je signais des
films sans les lire et que m'est arrivé
à l'époque tellement je les deux films
de faire deux films que j'avais de
tournage le matin et un autre après midi
et là il fait je me renseigne et qui met
en scène comment je m'appelle ouais mais
tu crois qu'à force de travail et que
des médiocres s'attendait médiocre toi
non mais j'ai j'ai été puni c'est normal
parce que les relations entre le public
et les artistes sont directement liés
même votre amant et maîtresses public
madoré au départ que des trucs marrants
et quand j'ai commencé à faire n'importe
quoi le public a dit merde et qui
n'importe quoi et comme une maîtresse
qu'on délaisse mais j'ai jamais pensé à
faire de films x sont tous genres tapas
pense être avant tout je suis trop
frileux alors il ya autre chose s'il est
bien un des meilleurs joueurs de france
gt gt gt fort joueur en faute et j'étais
moi je oui il en y injectant inventé il
ya déjà des adeptes de la pétanque coll
tapez dans google oui c'est un oui mais
en italie les gens et joue il paraît
qu'à lyon il ya site avis il ya c'est un
sport adoré c'est un sport national et à
lille
c'est ça qui a inventé ça il faut qu'on
pense t il faut un matériau nouveau il
faut un composé chimique
ça joue comment la pétanque au
l'expliqué bien sûr un billard les mêmes
règles la paix tant que jeune est bon
c'est tout tu veux pas tirer c'est tout
vêtu de mai tabbou circuit il se
rappelle un cochonnet
est-ce que tu bois non j'ai qu'est ce
que j'ai vu tu as vu boxer but ans j'ai
bu je me suis arrêté il ya vraiment 20
ans mais encore 20 ans j'avais bu
pour plusieurs vies c est dingue je je
faisais ma maman livre de porto
quotidiennement mon litre de whisky
quotidiennement et à tarbes c'était une
bouteille et demi de toutes manières par
repas de 20,5 royal quand on ne voit
comme ça comme tu viens conserver ces
baisses que j'élimine ça ne pas garder
tout ce mois à 8 ans et et non je ne
vois plus de 20 du tout je prends des
apéritifs à la marque possède un qui
fait pas de mal qu'il fait pas de mal
célia large et jaune où était sa fille
dis-moi tu fumes et quand même quatre à
cinq paquets de cigarettes par jour ça y
allait ou des jeunes allument à une deux
batteurs ça suffisait ouais jusqu'à
lundi matin
mais qu'est ce que tu penses de
l'interview vous bien ouais beaucoup de
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics entrées bière 1
je suis désolé pour les fumeurs je suis
désolé pour les fumeurs c'est pas
marrant pour eux et dans la rue que
suppose de l'interdiction de fumer des
cigarettes dans la rue hébert choses
étranges choc bon fou rire à [ __ ] de
ta me dérange pas du tout mais j'ai
remarqué qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
femmes que d'hommes qui filme dans la
rue et ça ça mange à l'aide rue pourquoi
la regarde après l'interdiction de fumer
dans les entreprises aux usa la suisse à
son tour ne mégote pas avec la cigarette
la ville de neuchâtel qui a déjà
interdit l'usagé de la cigarette dans
certains lieux publics s'apprêtent à
mettre en application une autre loi
beaucoup plus sévères ce elle l'a
approuvée par 62% de la population lors
d'un référendum à partir du 1er juillet
92 il sera interdit de fumer dans la rue
c'est le groupe anti tabac de neuchâtel
qui est à l'origine de cette initiative
[Musique]
nous avons provoqué des sourires si ce
n'est des sarcasmes auprès de certains
certains pensaient qu'il s'agissait
d'une atteinte à une liberté
fondamentale je ne crois pas quand il
s'agit de détruire sa santé parce que
vraiment maintenance et des enfants qui
fument déjà dans la rue en tout cas pour
montrer que cette image là n'est pas
n'est pas banal aujourd'hui qu'ils
allaient petit cadeau les kiosques qui
votent plus du tout de cigarettes
c'est qu'on veut côté des eaux ici on
prononce pas fumer à l'école l'euro va
tous deux les forces loyales et prouve
qu elle on écrase de cigarettes dès
qu'ils repartent seront se rallument il
n'y a pas d'enfant qui fait main c'est
quelque chose de grave et faire de la
prévention c'est très bien il faut
qu'ils prennent conscience de la gravité
du problème et on a un atout c'est la
santé il faut la conserver le plus
longtemps possible
en fait en suisse fondé beaucoup plus
obéissants que séjour en france
la chose votée est une chose acquise est
admise
donc peu importe les réactions que nous
avions avant avancer le débat
après le débat c'est la votation est le
résultat de la votation et tout le monde
s'y soumet c'est une vraiment je crois
chez nous l'esprit démocratique dans le
sens le plus complet du terme
une votation qui n'est pas sans
déclenché de violentes réactions et pas
seulement en suisse un stack incroyable
que cette loi est passée c'est un manque
de compréhension des habitants
c'est une atteinte à la liberté
individuelle qui est compétente grave
j'ai pas l'impression que j'emmerde les
gens fumaient fxx à des enterrements
après tout c'est de se faire faute
français moi j'ai besoin de vivre aussi
chez un citoyen je peux des impôts donc
c'est vraiment inadmissible sont les
emmerdes
interviewé dans la rue à neuchâtel est
de l'info s de l'intox d'harry à
l'oreille des châtels s de l'info s de
l'intox sa majesté à vous de jouer
c'est une atteinte à la liberté que dans
près de fumer dans la rue lorsque cette
intox
l'intox verjee je crois que c'est de
l'info parce que c'est typiquement
suisse
c'est typiquement suisse toi tu m'as dit
quoi vrai vrai toi tu m'a dit ah ça
remonte pour philippe guérand on écoute
l'expert philippin est les clients free
en a les clients pour philippe berre au
triomphe triomphe huguette qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que ça pète entre nous quoi
ça suffit arrêter de donner toutes les
bonnes réponses c'est de l'intox
le score est bien là mal baisées appelle
pas sur la [ __ ] 3 2 pour l'aréna
depuis 25 ans à chaque fois qu'on lit
une interview de toi tu fais ton mais
accumule pas tu dis j'essaie d'aborder
ma carrière à cause du jeu mes études à
cause des femmes mais dont deux
musiciens à cause du trac
tu dis toujours j'aimerais recommencer
ma carrière pourquoi cette espèce de
d'autoflagellation comme ça depuis 25
ans oui est idiot un que ça sert à rien
n'avance à rien et puis tout à l'heure
je vois que ma carrière au parti
intervenus au cinéma est arrêté pendant
six ans était revenue avec me qui s'est
passé comment on bat divine norme qui
est un grand fou d'un artiste il a sévi
dans un royaume un peu dingue
et puis le tonnage les tonnages
s'effectue de manière tellement
décontractée tandis que ces îles il
s'amuse on va faire un metteur en scène
qui s'amusent honteux de patrons samu
c'est fabuleux
ouais mais il a il a un temps à lui qui
fait que ces films sont un petit peu
toujours en marge des autres c'est en
fait c'est le sait le marco ferreri
français c'est vrai les choses alors tu
as dit j'aimerais jouer avec des jeunes
mais c'est vrai que leur humour un peu
dure un peu incisif un peu la thaïlande
ça me fait peur non là oui d'accord mais
j'ai j'ai abordé avec un garçon cap
plein de talent j'ai fait et qui a fait
du café théâtre qui est un nom café
théâtre d'ailleurs et j'ai fait un essai
à jouer de ses pièces et puis elle était
trop trop trop folle était trop folle
les gens vont pas bien pigé il étonnant
le but ya quand même la gaffe il ya kiwi
fait pas de talent apporte un débat
intitulé ma fille qui est oui il est
très gentil arts et bien c'est drôle ni
fait ce qu'il fait c'est très drôle
serpente à son très chaud mais bon on va
en voir un lambin fischer
[Musique]
mentionnons où les barbus rentrer par la
porte de droite s'il vous plaît les
barbus n'obligeait de réguler le flux du
magasin les marques et barbu à l'entrée
la juste la porte là pour chanter ici
c'est laisser les femmes blondes ici ici
c'est les hommes sans lunettes vous
prenez l'entrée des hommes alenia
devrait marquer le sigle lunettes avons
été obligés vous aviez la devise la
moustache en rentrant monsieur oui vous
l'avez pas prise dans le magasin à
moustache non sur celle des gens
maintenant ils vont semer des moustaches
et reçoit où la vie est rentrant merci
messieurs
d'accord je suis vous aviez des lunettes
en rentrant d'accord parce que les gens
mettent des lunettes et 110 magasins
vous aviez charbo d'accord mais gai et
noir monsieur médinois en jeu si vous
avez ces mêmes femmes ok il est pas il
ya des gens qui pique les femmes des
autres dans les magasins allons obliger
contrôler c'est à vous c'est payé cet
article il est payé ok merci madame a
piqué un truc de moins de 100 francs
donc tu l'emmènes il est tombé d'accord
c'était tellement 2 quoi qu'il en soit
nous on a des lois très strictes
donc tu la mets dans le bureau et il
boit un peu la gueule
mais je vais te demander quelque chose
je me gratte je me gratte on sortait des
package à [ __ ] moi on pouvait piquer
de ce que vous voulez c'est bon j'ai
tout payé
bon allez on va passer et repasser
non regardez je sais vous avez des
plombages parce que des fois ça fait ça
quand les gens voient la bouche noire
voilà vous le bordel là dont on voit la
bouche au bord ok on va vous montrer vos
plongées avec caméra comme ça ne va pas
de voiliers la caméra la halle et ouvrez
la bouche très beau film
voilà c'est déplombage elle n'a rien
piqué la dame
ouvrez la bouche regardez voilà le boxon
là dedans je vois la bouche en trois ans
le bordel s'est immiscé truc ouvrir un
gentil je les tresses mon badge 13 c'est
ça mettez la main devant la bouche est
repassée retirer la main alors passé en
mettant la main devant la bouche à les
incidences sélectionné monsieur papa
s'est passé l'an passé c'est la
casquette auquel la casquette
ah bon papa c'est quoi passer de
regarder ça ça me plaît mettez la sur la
tête mettez les sur la tête repassé à
voyait retirer la retirer leurs auteurs
là
non c'est la casquette a tant elles sont
plombées comme ça on s'en priver comme
ma soeur ouais
michaud alors là
finalement j'aurais été embauché à plein
temps ils ont dit que j'étais pas assez
qu'on a un métier faut être très con
surveillants et quand tu étais petit
piqué dans les prises uniques quand je
goulet tout ce qui passe
ouais et là tu tombes sur baffie quoi
ouais mais c'est vrai que toi tu as été
médium pour gagner ta vie un moment mais
pas longtemps huit 8 mois après huit
mois et était employé par de vieilles
anglaises qui te faisait ray chez tout
un bruit de ces études oui c'est vrai ça
c'était d'impasse
cardinal mercier a ainsi 16h plein dans
l'occupation sous l'eau sous
l'occupation allemande et
il y avait là deux anglaises et
violoniste qui s'appelait monsieur
claude guerre nous il s'appelle toujours
céder vivent d'ailleurs et les sentiers
en moi des dons de médium sont des dons
que l'on ne perçoit pas soi-même et
lydia je vais t'emmener tu seras très
bien payé et j'ai nourri d'ailleurs ma
fausse mère pendant huit mois d'extrême
frère avec cet argent là et en argent
liquide français et j'allais le soir
chez ces deux dames y avait deux
médecins donc c'était très très sérieux
c'était vraiment de très très sérieux
c'était très suivie mais c'était
vraiment en transe ça m'est complètement
complètement parce qu'il se passait
trois heures j'ai plutôt comme s'ils
étaient endormis par du pain total
uniquement et je revenais à moi très
suis encore une fois on me payait et
georges avait un os ou est ce que les
anglais devraient procurer ou soit pas
parce que je revis y avait pu métro pour
réintégrer mon avis à pied et j'étais
très dans un état très très dans la rue
j'ai senti mon d'éclairer les gens et
des [ __ ] arrivé plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs que les allemands c'est
bizarre que je vais dire la personne ne
va le croire mais que les allemands qui
étaient sur le point de m'interpeller
partait il avait peur de cette paix de
silhouettes en réel et de mauvais jeux
je vais craquer les trucages et
électrique c'était j'ai arrêté parce que
je devenais fou parce que sam la vie est
trop belle pour se lancer là dedans mais
il paraît que tu as vu aussi des
soucoupes volantes c'est vrai fin dit
oui mais oui on va aussi plus banal ça
l'an passé + ballon j'en ai vu très
nettement une de ses passions à deuxième
mais j'en ai vu une face à l'époque
ouvre bah oui justement c'est la
question que j'avais devant est-ce que
la première est-ce que la première
c'était pas dans l'époque où anne au nom
du tout avant non la tête et les
voitures qui avait six roues mais non
quand je vivais non celle que tu as vu
dans l'estérel par exemple été avec la
tt avec une chanson qui s'appelle sourit
jamais souri peut en voir l'émission ce
soir et j'avais je conduisais une
traction de performance 11 dg oui
j'étais pas bourré du tout et abandonné
dans un virage dans l'aude estérel je
vois très nettement une chose très
spécial aux couleurs multiples qui fait
des trajectoires très bizarre qui
s'arrêtent peut pas évaluer la distance
vue je ne connaissais pas le diamètre de
cette chose non identifiables et j'ai
tout heureux ne seront pas de tout
rouillé en est très heureux je m'arrête
et je dis regardez la mer regarder
tourner dans les pommes et sa souris
peut en témoigner et souris qui étaient
là deeper du machin le obligé d'y croire
je descend de la voiture comme un héros
pour dépourvu qui prouve comment ça va
ou pas c'est de partir la case soucoupe
réel s'est passé est là un angle droit
elle est partie je remonte en voiture je
me précipite dans un autre virage l'airé
aperçu et puis il est parti il semble
ici à mourir du tout les gens quand tu
leur as raconté que t'es vu une soucoupe
volante qui t'ont pas dit avant l'abbé
soury
mouais ça veut sourire d'ailleurs
s'adapter sourire ce soir plein de
personnes je m'en fous j'ai vu de ce
couple hollande plaît c'est une chance
c'est pour moi c'est oui mais c'est un
pas très loin ça me regarde un élu tu
tues tu veux que je te manque quelque
chose doute bizarre qui se passe dans le
ciel ses désirs mais ce luxembourg cet
appareil magasin les luxembourgeois ont
un sens de la propriété particulièrement
développée après s'être distingué en
concentrant le plus grand nombre de
banques ou mètres carrés le grand duché
s'est mise en tête de privatiser le ciel
à l'origine de cette décision une
histoire de gruchet mal placé lors de la
construction d'un tunnel routier à
luxembourg ville
en 1985 on avait terminé une grosse
partie de l' ouvrage et qu'on devait
continuer par un viaduc
est propriétaire des gens à la sortie du
viaduc
nous on fait des reproches de monter une
grue à tour sur leur sueur qui passait
au dessus de leur jardin et nous ont dit
que c'était interdit au luxembourg bref
la grue haute de 50 mètres empiéter sur
le bout de ciel qui revient de droit aux
propriétaires elles mettaient leur
sécurité en péril la sphère a été portée
devant les tribunaux
retrouvez que la côte cellules nous
garantissait contre tous tout le porter
à notre propriété que ce soit
directement ou indirectement au dessus
on a violé notre espace aérien
les arguments de la défense ont été
retenus et les plaignants l'ont emporté
la grüne plus le droit d'être actionnée
sous peine d'une très forte amende
personne n'ayant contester le jugement
c'est un cas de jurisprudence et
aujourd'hui n'importe quel citoyen
luxembourgeois pourrait interdire le
passage d'une grue au dessus de sa
maison un droit qu'ils ne partagent pas
avec son voisin français il a été décidé
en français une seule fois à ma
connaissance que comme c'était une
emprise provisoire sur votre terrain eh
bien vous ne pouviez pas vous plaindre
ça a été jugée à rouen en 1982 dans tous
les cas le tribunal grand ducal
privilégie les intérêts privés à ce
l'utilité publique
à ce titre mieux qu'une grue les
luxembourgeois pourrait interdire le
passage au dessus de chez eux d'avion
jugés trop bruyants
l'afer est restée discrète si bien que
ce peuple là n'a pas conscience que le
ciel lui appartient
aujourd'hui
son propriétaire de l'espace aérien au
dessus de leurs maisons s de l'info s de
l'intox d'alcool à l'oreille
alors maintenant mesdames messieurs
pendant que la reine d'angleterre et
sarah ferguson se demande si c'est de
l'info ou de l'intox
enfin vous faites pareil chez vous
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corti on m'a dit
tu fais ça tu dessin menu manu s'en
foutent façon ils descendent pas été
commenté manu katché le 6 avril au new
morning cher
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
m
les moins
[Musique]
jackon
là
[Musique]
waouh
oh
ça
où
m
[Musique]
oui nouveau king
m
kim jong-il comme ça
francoeur
c est
oh
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
luxembourgeois son propriétaire de
l'espace aérien au dessus de leurs
maisons s de l'info est de l'intox
sahara à toi de jouer
de l'intox tu crois pas non c'est
ridicule c'est ridicule ça fera plaisir
et vous majesté je pense que ça donne un
faux parce que le sens de la propriété
au luxembourg c'est aussi beaucoup ce
des banques oui toi tu m'as dit que
c'était de l'info un vrai oui vrai bon
on écoute l'expert philippe gas huguette
vous êtes vraiment pas chouette
c'était de l'info ça il a jeté les gants
on applaudit
a commenté à mon fils ou non sur ce
sujet aucun commentaire à faire par
contre mon petit thierry courtois que ce
soir avec toute l'équipe
nous sommes heureux de fêter le 100ème
sujet info intox depuis début de cette
émission
tout retombe
je te propose car le temps je te
proposes tu irais je te propose mon
petit thierry après devenir ont fait
toute une boum dans le cadre mais même
venir le public on se réunit tous on va
manger un peu de champagne
non si je comprends bien ça fait ton
100e score finalement non parce qu'il y
en a que j'ai pas donné à ben ya des
jours je m'en bats les couilles je suis
même pas venu un peu le toit finale
non seulement la vioque à répudier la
jeune non plus à la torche et ses deux
gardes
le terme dames et messieurs qui attrape
répudié sarrazin est ce que vous pouvez
lui pardonner mais cnc pardonne tout
elle pardonne tout c'est un talent merci
mais j'espère
ah bah ça vaut le coup d'être venu quand
même ouais ouais j'ai perdu le jeu et
mon mari aussi aux un ton mari c'est sur
lui il a gagné des cornes faut bien le
dire
majesté vous prenez votre petit
téléviseur vous regardez les cadeaux
philips qui défilent et vous me dites
celui que vous voulez
[Musique]
attention nicolas la chaîne hifi
colonnes ligne entièrement nouvelle elle
comprend un cd programmables un ampli
turbo basse générateur un tuner une
double platine k7 autorise burr brown en
angleterre
on touche au but tu as tourné sans avait
dit tu mets tu aussi servi mille messes
ce qui est pas mal quand même
ce que tu servi le dimanche tu servait
trois messes le dimanche matin
mais je corrige ses 126 film ouais et à
la 26 de biens et mais ce plus de 1000
oui bah oui parce que dimanche je me
farsi c'est les trois messes les vêpres
saint sacrement et tous les jours de la
semaine une messe je serai ses
pensionnaires pendant huit ans avec deux
mois de vacances dakarois renard s'est
vite fait tu es resté huit ans chez les
frères oui pas mal
l'esprit de famille oui on garde un bon
souvenir très beau j'aime tout je te
donne tu aimais les retraites
ils essaient d'en dans ses méthodes de
faire nous de nous coller de collégiens
les des enfants appelés par dieu et
c'est de faire et on fait rentrer au
séminaire et j'ai failli je commençais à
avoir des saintes vierges partout je
commençais à avoir des jeux n'est pas
loin 1 mais c'est pas fini et 10 mois
un jour tu as découvert la bouche les
fesses les seins all à 1 et la femme
était venue de la femme de la famille la
femme est devenue la deuxième religion
c'était à mais c'est un culte mais je
crois en dieu par la femme alors de
premier de la classe et est devenu non
pas avant dernier parce que la torre
lyon c'est vrai c'est devenu dernier
dernier j'y tenais institué beaucoup
j'étais beaucoup tu vient de confesser
là oui parce que j'ai dit ça notre
méchant mais si c'est l'alcool
bref
ce soir
m
[Musique]
darryl inutile de te demander si tu est
favorable au divorce très beau concept
utile et je regrette qu d'ivoire sied
pas de repas aussi copieux que doivent
un couteau au cou au moment des noces
l'homosexualité je suis vite égalité et
non pas moins un homme en face de tout
ça d'une banalité tout à fait normal
absolument normal tu as eu des
expériences homosexuelles quand même
jamais jamais jamais dans le bouquin que
j'écris j'ai ralenti une folle était
bourré vous avez trop d'eau explique
nous avons fait mais pour et je dis bien
chez vous on a essayé tous les moyens
pour et c'est absolument moi
personnellement je peux tuer beaucoup
sanofi jamais recommencer est ce que tu
es pour la peine de mort bah des fois il
a faudrait la plupart du temps non mais
des fois elle sera très utile dans
quelqu'un dans le cas de gens qu'il faut
vraiment du mal aux autres et qui mérite
une sanction et qui peuvent récidiver
sur tout cas des kurdes tout de suite
elle trace d'eux
jean guy qui font du mal et petits
peuvent recommencer
quels sont tes tableaux ou ou qu'est
devenu par plus près tout louis même
l'inceste
ah bah non sous préfecture venant pas
tout tout ce thème est grand mot je dis
tout ça peut être ou majuscule c'est un
petit plus est ce que tu crois aux
quelque chose qui nous dépasse c'est
évident oui oui oui
est ce que tu crois que dieu t'a donné
plus de donc à d'autres bah je sais pas
mais d'après ce que les gens disent
peut-être un peu plus les autres est-ce
que tu prendre 5 antoine de padoue will
[ __ ] dit rita fin by naim aarab
marié ma sphère trouver des tas de trucs
ou via sa page pas quelque chose je
m'adresse à lui et quand je retrouve pas
il a fait rarement et lâchement golta
sérieusement j'ai fait réciter des
patères des avait tout cela il n'est pas
fier est-ce que tu regrettes pas un peu
les fastes de l'église dans le temps non
je ne te mange à quatre femmes je trouve
qu'elle est encore beaucoup trop parce
que le papa n'est pas bush qui valait
milliards et conseils comme vous faire
bol de riz se reprendre
je
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu